place au prix du meilleur scénario et
pour remettre ce prix je vous avoue que
je suis fait un petit kiff un petit
plaisir en fait avant de faire cette
cérémonie
j'ai bien demandé si je pouvais inviter
qui je voulais on m'a dit oui kian qui
tu veux et donc la prochaine personne et
une remettante une personne que j'aime
énormément et pour remettre le prix du
meilleur scénario
mesdames et messieurs ma maman marie
josée qu'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
baa
[Musique]
bonsoir à tout bonsoir à tous bonsoir
mon lapin
cannes sa croisette ses stars quelle
émotion d'être ici ce soir
quand j'étais petit je regardais le
festival de cannes
et quand je voyais une comédienne
remettre un prix à quelqu'un je me
disais moi aussi un jour je remettrai un
prix je suis là devant vous ce soir
excusez moi alors je m'adresse à toi toi
la petite fille qui rêve devant la télé
et qui qui dit moi aussi j'aimerais
remettre a pris un jour et qui se
demandent comment faire et bien toi je
le dis oui j'ai dû coucher avec son père
j'ai fait cet enfant et 35 ans plus tard
je suis là devant vous et je réalisais
mes joies du piston mesdames et
messieurs merci merci à tous maman maman
maman faut que tu remettre un prix quand
même c'était là pour remettre un prix
fonction même si on peut avoir
l'enveloppent s'il vous plaît voilà
merci beaucoup je sais que t'es vue mais
quand même on est là pour féliciter
quelqu'un
et le prix du meilleur scénario est
attribué à state of happiness lic landes
state of happiness une série de leur
régime unique de l'argent au pays
détient on lit comme chez nous on blague
l'ascap histoire qui mêle destin
g
sur fond de conquête pétrolières à la
fin des années 60 ans n'était pas net
oh
oui
[Musique]
merci merci merci au jury
merci à tout le monde d'abord je
remercie mes producteurs qui a été
incroyable du début à la fin on a
beaucoup travaillé ensemble mais aussi
la télévision norvégienne et nos
magnifiques réalisateur et une
distribution merveilleuse merci
infiniment
[Applaudissements]